♪ ♪
>> Tammy: WELCOME BACK TO
"HANNITY," I'M TAMMY BRUCE.
OF THE NEW EXTREME DEMOCRATIC
PARTY CONTINUES TO DRIFT FURTHER
AND FURTHER LEFT WEARIED OF
EMBRACING OPEN BORDERS, HIGHER
TAXES, AND OF COURSE, FAR LESS
TO SOCIALISM.
IF NONE OF THAT DOES ANY GOOD
FOR HUMANITY AS WE'VE SEEN
HISTORICALLY.
GET THIS, EVEN DEMOCRATIC
INSIDERS ARE NOW ADMITTING THAT
BERNIE SANDERS HAS A PATH TO
POLITICAL.
"BERNIE SANDERS PLAYED NO
PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN IS CONSIDERED SEARS
LAY.
THEY'RE RECONSIDERING SANDERS
CHANCES."
IF THAT'S NOT DISTURBING ENOUGH,
AOC SAID TO BE QUITE HONORED TO
BE HIS VICE PRESIDENT WHILE
ADMITTING SHE'S TOO YOUNG TO
EVEN HOLD THE OFFICE.
TONIGHT, IT COULD NOT BE MORE
CLEAR THE NEW EXTREME DEMOCRATS
ARE RUNNING THE PARTY AND
DRIVING THE NARRATIVE AND
PUTTING SO-CALLED MODERATES LIKE
JOE BIDEN, IF YOU WANT TO CALL
HIM A MODERATE, PUTTING THEM ON
THE DEFENSIVE, WHILE HE CLINGS
TO THE FRONT RUNNER STAND US,
SHE COULD USE TO BE PLAGUED BY A
WEAK RECORD AND HIS SONS SHADY
DEALINGS OVERSEAS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I DON'T THINK TRUMP IS
PLAYING CHESS OBJECTIVES, HE'S
PLAYING HUNGRY HUNGRY HIPPO.
I GET WHY THE PRESIDENT WAS A
CIRCUS, A CIRCUS IS A CIRCUS AND
IT'S GOOD FOR EVERYBODY THAT
GETS CONFUSED AND WE TALK ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN.
OF WHEN WE ONCE GOING AFTER
HUNTER BIDEN, OR THESE GUYS, ITS
GOING TO BE CRAZY.
>> Tammy: YEAH, THAT'S IN THE
FUTURE, CRAZY.
IF REMEMBER, JOE BIDEN IS
LITERALLY ON TAPE ADMITTING TO A
CRITICAL PRO.
LEVERAGING TAXPAYER AID TO GET
THE PROSECUTOR FIRED IN HIS ZERO
EXPERIENCE SON HUNTER.
NOT ONLY THAT, A PRIVATE
INVESTIGATION FROM THE PRIVATE
INVESTIGATION FIRM IS ALLEGING A
NEW COURT FILING THAT HUNTER
BIDEN IS ACTUALLY THE SUBJECT OF
MULTIPLE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
INVESTIGATIONS.
BUT THE MEDIA WOULD RATHER JUST
IGNORE IT.
AND IGNORE JUST HOW DISCONNECTED
AND HOW
DANGEROUS AND HOW DESTRUCTIVE
THE NEW DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
BECOME.
JOINING ME NOW FREE AIR
REACTION, TRUMPET 2020 CAMPAIGN
SECRETARY, KAYLEE, ALONG WITH
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES" COLUMNIST
ANN FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
CHARLIE HURT AND
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER" SR.
CAMPAIGN REPORTER, KERRY PICKET.
TERRY, LET'S START WITH YOU THE
ENTIRE ENVIRONMENT HERE WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE MEDIA
COVERING THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
NATURE OF WHAT IT'S COVERING FOR
AND ACCUSING DONALD TRUMP
WANTING THE CIRCUS.
IF HE'S NOT IN CHARGE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE DIDN'T CHOOSE THE CANDIDATES.
THEY ARE DEALING WITH THE MESS
OF WHAT BARACK OBAMA LEFT THEM
IN THE WAKE OF OBAMACARE AND HIS
EIGHT YEARS.
SO, DONALD TRUMP IS SITTING BACK
AND TRYING TO RUN THE COUNTRY AT
THE SAME TIME.
OBVIOUSLY, I THINK ANY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS CAN BECOME A
NOMINEE, BUT THE DEMOCRATIC
MACHINE EFFECTIVELY BECAUSE IT'S
ANNOYED ONE.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT BIDEN, ARE
THEY SERIOUS ABOUT
BERNIE SANDERS?
>> RIGHT NOW, WE SING FOR IT ANY
STANDERS GOING BACK INTO THE
SPOTLIGHT AND REMEMBER, TAMMY,
THERE'S A PERIOD OF TIME
WHERE HE WAS NUMBER ONE.
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT WAS A
FREAKING OUT THE BEDS AND SO'S
THEY'RE SAYING, JOE, YOU BETTER
JUMP IN AT ONE POINT IN SAVE US.
THEN JOE BIDEN ALL OF A SUDDEN,
HE'S HAVING THE ENTANGLEMENTS
WITH HIS SON.
WE BEGIN TO SEE ELIZABETH WARREN
HAVE HER POP.
AND ALL OF US AND THEN THEY'RE
GOING BACK OUT AGAIN.
IF WE ARE SEEING BERNIE SANDERS
POP UP AGAIN AND WE ARE
BEGINNING TO WONDER AND IT COMES
AROUND A PERIOD >> Tammy: IT
COMES AROUND TO THE MEDIA IS
PAYING ATTENTION TO.
IT BERNIE SANDERS, AFTER THE
HEART ATTACK, HE'S NOT REALLY
TAKING ANYTHING BY THE MEDIA AS
WELL.
ELIZABETH WARREN WAS BECAUSE OF
THE ABSURD MEDICARE FOR ALL
$50 TRILLION CIRCUS AND SHE TOOK
SOME HEADS.
OF FOR THE MOMENT ANY ATTENTION
CAME TO THEM, THEY SINK.
IF CHARLIE, DO YOU THINK THIS IS
GOING TO BE ONE OF THE CASES WHE
EITHER THEY ARE HOPING HE WILL
AND NO ELIZABETH WARREN GOING
AWAY AND GOING DOWN, SOMEBODY'S
NOT GOING DOWN, BLOOMBERG.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS COMING OUT
IN THE NEXT MONTH OR TWO AS WE
HEAD INTO THE CAUCUS?
>> I HAVE TO SAY, TAMMY, ALL
ALONG I HAVE BELIEVED SOMEBODY
LIKE JOE BIDEN ALTHOUGH HE IS
COMPLETELY MARCHED AWAY FROM HIS
"DISINTEREST APPEARING LIKE A
SEA OF OBAMA" SORT OF PLATFORM.
HE MOST LIKELY REPRESENTS THE
BROAD CROSS-SECTION OF THE
PARTY.
AS YOU POINT OUT, HE'S RUNNING A
DISASTROUS CAMPAIGN.
IT WOULD NOT SURPRISE ME ONE BIT
TO SEE OUT OF ALL THE WRECKAGE
SEE A BERNIE SANDERS WIND UP
WITHOUT NOMINATION.
AFTER ALL, HE WON THE NOMINATION
AND 2016.
IF IT JUST SO HAPPENS THE DNC
AND THE HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN
GODS OF THE OTHER CONSPIRED TO
TAKE IT AWAY FROM HIM BUT IT
WOULD NOT SURPRISE ME.
I ALSO THINK THAT BERNIE SANDERS
WILL WIND UP AS THE NOMINEE FOR
THE PARTY, I THINK HE CLEARLY
LOSES AND NOT ONLY BECAUSE HE'S
CRAZY, ALL HIS POLICIES ARE
TOTALLY INFALLIBLE TO THE
GENERAL ELECTION
VOTERS BREED OF THEIR
UNPALATABLE
TO THE CROSS-SECTION OF
DEMOCRATS.
>> Tammy: WHEN I WAS ON THE
LEFT, EVEN BRING UP THE SUBJECT
IT'S A LEGITIMATE THING TO
DISCUSS.
MOVING FORWARD.
THAT IS FIVE STEPS FORWARD,
THREE STEPS BACK, WE CAN'T
DISMISS THE EFFORT THAT HAS TO
CHANGE THE MENTALITY OF
AMERICANS ON THE SCENE.
IF WE HAVE SEEN WHAT THEY DID
NOT ANTICIPATE WITH DONALD TRUMP
REMINDING THEM OF THE GREATNESS
OF THE AMERICAN IDEAL.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE REPUBLIC
AND CERTAINLY CAPITALISM.
OF AT THE SAME TIME, YOU'VE GOT
TO THE OTHER THING AND I'VE SEEN
THE HUNTER BIDEN DYNAMIC, A
LITTLE BIT OF A DISTRACTION, BUT
IT REALLY IN A WAY SITS AT A
QUARTER OF THE PROBLEM WITH THE
SWAMP.
IT'S THE NEPOTISM, THE MONEY,
AND YOU WONDER HOW DO YOU BECOME
A MULTIMILLIONAIRE IN PUBLIC
SERVICE?
NOW, THIS IS THE SCENE THAT
SEEMS TO EXPLAIN THAT TO A
RELEASE TRIP TO BEAR.
A DO YOU THINK THIS IS A HUNTER
BIDEN PROBLEM PER DAY.
IT WILL THIS AFFECT THE
JOE BIDEN IF HE CONTINUES TO
STAY AT THE TOP?
>> IT CERTAINLY WELL, TAMMY,
WHEN I TRAVEL THE NATIONS WITH
THE PRESIDENT'S RALLIES, ONE
THING I HEAR REPEATEDLY IS ABOUT
THE WASHINGTON SWAMP.
THE NOTION THAT POLITICIANS GO
IN, THEY ARE ENRAGED AND THEY
CROSS IT OFF THE TIME IN PUBLIC
SERVICE AND THERE'S NO BETTER
EXAMPLE OF THAT THAN HUNTER
BIDEN WHO HAD NO EXPERIENCE AND
OIL AND GAS AGAINST THE
LUCRATIVE CONGRESS IN UKRAINE.
THE LUCRATIVE DEAL IN CHINA,
COINCIDENTALLY, AFTER HIS FATHER
LEAVES THE FOREIGN RELATION BOTH
OF THE COUNTRY OR VISITS THEY
ARE IN THE CASE OF CHINA, THIS
IS AT THE CENTER.
OF WHEN HILLARY CLINTON HAD HER
EMAIL PROBLEM IN THE BLEACH
BIDDING AND ALL OF THIS CAME
OUT, CNN, AND AS BC, THEY DID
THEIR BEST TO HIDE IT.
IF I SAW IT HAPPEN, THE SCANDALS
IF I SAW IT HAPPEN, THE SCANDALT
IF I SAW IT HAPPEN, THE SCANDALO
HIDE IT FROM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
SMART, THEY SEE THROUGH ITS, AND
WILL SEE THE SCANDALS FOR WHAT I
WILL SEE THE SCANDALS FOR WHAT T
IS LIKELY DID WITH THE
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Tammy: I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S DIFFERENT AND ALL
OF THAT AND WERE DISCUSSING
HERE, IT'S SOCIAL MEDIA.
ITS CABLE TELEVISION.
IF THE FACT THAT REAL-TIME NOW
YOU CAN SEE THE NEWS ON THE
SMARTPHONE.
YOU CAN GET INFORMATION AS IT'S
OCCURRING.
MAYBE THE HUNTER BIDEN THING, IF
HE ONLY HAD THREE NETWORKS TO
RELY ON THAT WERE COVERING UP,
YOU WOULD NOT HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THOSE DETERMINATIONS.
THEN YOU'VE GOT ALEXANDRA KAZU
CORTEZ WHO SEEMS TO BE
YOUR THE REPRESENTATION OF THE
PROBLEM WHEN IT COMES TO THE
VOTING, ECONOMICALLY, HISTORICAL
LITERACY.
SHE DETACHED YOURSELF TO BERNIES
SHE DETACHED YOURSELF TO BERNIEN
SHE DETACHED YOURSELF TO BERNIEE
SHE DETACHED YOURSELF TO BERNIES
SHE DETACHED YOURSELF TO BERNIE.
OF CLEARLY IT'S NOT THE VANITY
PARTY ANYMORE, BUT YOU SEE THE
SOCIAL MEDIA AS PART OF
THE CHANGE IN HOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE RESPONDING IN WHAT
THEY ARE WILLING TO PUT UP WITH
BECAUSE WE'RE LEARNING MORE
EVERY DAY.
>> CERTAINLY, SOCIAL MEDIA HAS A
LOT TO DO WITH IT, BUT REMEMBER,
SHIRA
TOIRA
TO PA
TO PROVIDE A LOT OF ENERGY TO
THE DEMOCRATS IN THE PRIMARIES
THAT THEY CAN'T PROVIDE.
IF SHE'S NOT OLD ENOUGH.
IF UNFORTUNATELY, THEY HAVE TO
WAIT UNTIL 2024.
>> Tammy: IF THEY IMAGINE THIS
IS THE FUTURE, THEY'VE GOT SOME
BIGGER PROBLEMS THAN YOU CAN
IMAGINE BECAUSE THE AMERICANS
HAVE REJECTED THAT IN 2016 AND
THE REJECTING IT NOW.
WITH EVERYTHING ELSE WE'VE SEEN
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO REJECT
IT IN 2020.
IT'S A LEGACY OF THE AMERICAN